joining us now is South Carolina Center
Lindsey Graham Senator you know the
president wants to set a positive tone
but is it an accurate one yeah
no I mean you know to be honest with you
life is pretty bad for most Americans
right now we went from energy
independent to being dependent on energy
uh you know all gas prices are up the
borders broken uh crime is rampant
throughout our country uh the bottom
line is Americans are hurting he's
disconnected from their hurt he doesn't
understand what's going under the Border
he's never been to the Border he's a
really a dangerously incompetent
commander-in-chief we withdrew from
Afghanistan and you see what's happening
over there but what I can't get over is
how he can talk about an America that
most people don't relate to he's
isolated he's insulated he's not being
told the truth about how life is in
America and I'm hoping he will go to the
border and find out that when it comes
to being a border patrol agent and
living on the border a southern border
life is pretty miserable
you know it's unbelievable Center you
know him well he's actually enraged
going crazy dropping the F-bomb in the
White House rattling through the East
Wing according to a new book because the
borders broken and the no Solutions are
you kidding me was he paying attention
to what he signs with his executive
orders undoing what president Trump had
done because basically Trump did it
yeah his policies are not working at the
border and title 42 is about to expire
President Biden could reinstate title 42
deportation Authority with a stroke of a
pen every Democrat voted against
extending title 42 in the Senate every
Republican voted for it when title 42
goes away as a deportation tool you're
going to double the number of illegal
immigrants coming into the country in
about a week we're going to have a
hundred thousand illegals coming across
the border a week in about a week and
he's done nothing to fix the problem
he's never been to the Border it is so
unconscionable for him not to go to the
border and listen to the agents and
people trying to control the Border what
life is like along our Southern border
the fact that he doesn't go shows to me
he's disconnected and he doesn't give a
damn right if he really gave a day by
the way we don't even have to get to the
Border
yeah he doesn't have to drop it by the
way it's in the White House
White House and go to the Border
all right get your ass up to the Border
well I don't think he's going to do it I
think he's going to go right to Delaware
where he's happiest he's just trying to
get that kickstand going so he can bike
again uh Senator earlier today you were
one of the 18 Republicans who voted for
the 1.7 trillion Omnibus it's over 4 000
pages long among the things in it we
understand 15 billion of pet projects
jammed in there money's being spent on
things like Michelle Obama's uh by a
trail and building Nancy Pelosi's houses
oh yeah not our houses but dedicated to
her uh you called it a train wreck why
sign it yeah
well at the end of the day I care about
the men and women in uniform like you do
the buying budget increased defense
spending by five percent inflation is
over seven percent so what did we do
today we increased defense spending by
10 percent the buying budget increased
non-defense spending by 13 we flipped it
and the bill I voted for today
non-defense spending went up five
percent defense spending went up 10
percent the men and women of the
military got a raise and they got more
money than inflation and if you did
nothing you're reducing defense spending
in a time of great danger the process
sucks it was a train wreck I'm hoping
the House Republicans when they get in
charge will pass 12 separate bills not
one big monstrous bill at the end and I
have a better choice of sitting you know
cutting the men and women in the
military's ability to defend the nation
or voting for a 4 000 page Bill I'm
hoping Kevin McCarthy can fix that on
the house side to give us a little
leverage in this send it into my house
colleagues you got every right to
complain but if you send over a budget
that cuts defense or doesn't keep up
with inflation it will be dead on
arrival my number one goal as a member
of the United States Senate is to defend
this nation and you cannot have defense
budgets below inflation when the world
is on fire that's why I voted for it
Senator Lindsey Graham have a great
Christmas thanks so much
Merry Christmas we'll see what the house
yeah you got it uh we'll see what the
house does now hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else